when you think of Wrigley the first
thing coming your mind is the grass the
marquee out front and this world war
it's like one of the main body parts of
Wrigley Field I'm Darrell Wilson I'm a
scoreboard operator for Chicago Cubs
[Music]
I've been working at Wrigley Field since
1987 we're gonna Phyllis one of the
oldest ballpark besides Boston he's been
around for over a hundred years and
basically nothing has changed in the
school board since 1938 in the
scoreboard we have at least three guys
if we're lucky for what a Cubs game is
going on my job is to post scores
anybody ending and pitching changes
throughout the league once all the games
start in the scoreboard is it's pretty
chaotic you're writing scores down on
your clipboard and you change the scores
while you're also yelling at other guys
to change their scores and their games
gets it know it's hot it's very noisy
the walkways are look narrow you got
plates
numbers everywhere the switching of the
scoreboard plate starts with a shift
punch just the tips are popping out of
the slot the plates are made of a
lighter thin metal you definitely have
to latch you want to make sure that
they're locked in so if the winds
blowing out they won't blow out at you
or something like that you're running up
and down and change the scores for eight
different games oh it's definitely hard
work if viewers outstanding is there's
just like a 360-degree view of the
entire ballpark and enable it that's
like looking out to your backyard and
have the perfect lawn I mean it's that's
what it's feel like walking out you just
feel feel proud you know you're just
proud of your work and the work that you
guys put into it the reason why I
believe that the school board is special
to fans because it still keeps that old
luster of the old-time ballpark I've
seen a lot of modern parks but we really
feel has an authentic original feel of
how baseball began
[Music]
you